so we've been trying to find the
velocity cart in the velocity of the
person in terms of the relative velocity
of the person jumping in the reference
frame of the moving cart the mass of the
person in the mass of the cart we've
already solved this in the ground frame
now I would like to solve this in which
my reference frame is the moving frame
so our pictures in the moving frame were
actually much easier because the moving
frame is traveling with the final speed
of the cart at the final interaction
after the interaction is done in this
moving frame the cart is at rest they're
moving together you're sitting in the
cart you're moving at the same speed the
person jumped off with speed u relative
to the cart
the tricky part was to realize that in
the ground frame when the cart is at
rest here in the ground frame an
observer moving with speed VC would see
the person in the cart moving backwards
in the moving frame with a speed minus
VC so now we can apply the momentum
principle to these two states in the
moving frame we have that momentum of
the system initially equals momentum of
the system finally now the initial
initial momentum is just minus MP plus
em cart the cart notice the minus V cart
and the final momentum is equal to just
M person you and so we see that V cart
equals minus and person you / M person
plus MC which is exactly the same result
that we got in the ground frame but it
was actually much easier to solve in the
moving frame